[Music]
one of the things that people have asked
me from time to time is like what was
your best game yeah and what was your
most important game and what game you
decided the most money you ever made and
when you wonder the US Championship
title what game was important you know
these types of questions but sometimes
sometimes very interestingly people ask
what was your most nerve-wracking game
that's kind of a different answer right
I mean well it's a game that you were
most nervous about and you know we
always have those last round nervousness
nurse and you know everything's on the
line that the championship and blah blah
blah but by far and not even close my
most nerve-wracking game came in the
1984 US Championship and my opponent
wasn't a man by the name of Kamran
Shirazi and Cam'ron born in Iran he had
come to the United States and he was an
extraordinarily gifted chess player it
was enormous ly talented and could play
a plethora of positions really really
really well and hang his queen like you
know shocking blunders and just fabulous
fabulous games and this was a struggle
obviously the US Championship it was a
crucial crucial event for this that the
other thing pride prizes everything at
stake and I was really stunned that when
I had come early for the event the event
was held in Berkeley California
just of course across the bay from San
Francisco and a place we call berserk
Lee berserk Lee California cars the
zhurqis California and we played at the
University Cal Berkeley campus and all
the players stayed at a hotel that was
near just off campus nearby very easy
walk and I came in and there was Kamran
Shirazi playing blitz chess five minute
blitz chess with Roman gingy Hashmi Lee
and they were just going for hours and
hours and I'm saying you know like guys
the tournament's gonna be starting and
things like this and throughout the
whole event the whole event there was
just like non-stop blitz between the two
of them I was like there was two
parallel tournaments going on there
blitz sessions and the US Championship I
wondered if they ever got any sleep they
were always in the lobby of the hotel
playing blitz so I asked Roman I said
Roman you know what's the stakes said
we're playing ten dollars a game ten
dollars a game and I have wow this is
really cool and I said what's the score
in he said something like I'm plus sixty
which means you know after hundred hours
of play 200 hours of play whatever it
was he was up 60 games or six hundred
dollars said well you guys aren't just
paying each other after play no no no no
no he said Cameron's going to pay me out
of his prize money that he wins here in
the US Championship and I thought that
was kind of cool you know like you know
this is America the land of credit you
have to pay right away
I'll pay on to come you know and it was
really an interest it was an interesting
situation because there are 16 players
but there are ten prizes ten
for those players who were not in the
top ten they were awarded money of $100
a point okay so and obviously if you
made in the top ten you made better
prices than $100 a point so they're just
playing day after day night after night
there blitz games and I'm just kind of
watching in from time to time and Conrad
is having the worst tournament of his
life he loses a game he loses a game he
loses a game now keep in mind when
you're playing in the u.s. championship
you're playing the strongest
grandmasters in the nation they're
looking for their points they're like
sharks right who's ever bleeding in the
water they're going after him and calm
run is the blood in the water and
everybody's going after Cameron for a
point well this goes on five rounds six
rounds the guys losing game after game
eight rounds nine ten rounds so all of
my colleagues my nearest rivals have
gotten the victory over comrade and soon
it's going to be my turn right and now
it's like the most nerve-wracking game
like this streak has got to stop I mean
Cameron's such a very very strong chess
player he deserves to be in the US
championship he's having a
mathematically impossible event he's
going to beat somebody and it just
better not be me so before the game I
was a bundle of nerves everything I've
been telling and and so forth and so on
and I spoiler spoiler alert before I get
into the game I just have to share
that comrade in fact did not yay lose
all of his games yay he made a draw one
draw in the whole tournament
it gets all the competitors that draw of
course was with Roman jeez really
$50 but this point C was ahead and so
you know you had those games where is a
hilarious story you have those games
where you're the big favorite your your
a your King Kong and there's a lesser
gorilla in your myths and you're
supposed to beat that guy but you know
that's when things can go wrong
right and here goes this game so I'm
white and I open D form now the sad
thing about Cameron it was completely
and I mean utterly ridiculously
impossible to prepare for him he could
play anything I mean literally anything
and he would often do it at the spur of
the moment so if you looked at his
databases of games and if you saw his
chess history would do you no good so I
had a nice walk before the game had
tried to calm down I played d4 tried to
imagine what he would play and of course
I was nowhere close c5 not completely
unexpected d5 d6 now this is strange
because this is a kind of an open
invitation to me if I play the move c2
c4 we're kind of in the Queen's pawn
opening the standard thing and if I play
the move e to e for it's a kind of a
reversal now I'm playing an e4 opening
okay
let's just keep it calm keep it quiet
see four and now I'm thinking okay in my
mind he could play a kinks fianchetto
like a Kings Indian defense maybe a
benoni or he might switch he might play
a straight benoni g6e for now this is a
this is an important point those of you
who do you know about the gingy Indian
the gingy Indian okay well there's Roman
gingy hush belly you know that did the
gingy in me and Joanna
you've heard about it exactly okay so
that fellow Roman gingy hush Billy
pioneered this line where the night
actually the the actual move order of
the gingy Indian is in this position to
play g6 oops
go ahead c4 so we kind of get what
happened in my game with comrade and in
this position Roman gingy Hodja really
took which when he introduced this whole
concept was really revolutionary I mean
if you stop and think about it black is
playing g6 Bishop g7 getting a beautiful
bishop on the long diagonal investing to
Tempe in developing his bishop and then
he just gives it up for free he just
gives it away and the idea of Romans
which was I thought really really clever
is to follow it up with this really out
of the world type of move f7 f5 like
what does that move have to do with
anything that Romans concept was
extremely admirable his idea is to take
advantage to take control over the e4
square very simply blacks intention is
to play Knight f6 94 Queen a5
so Roman being close friend of mine we
did a lot of analysis together so I was
familiar with his idea and so in this
position after the move g6 I did not
play Knight c3 Bishop g7 e4 because I
was fearful that in their blitz action
come run had learned something I was
ready to play Bishop c3b c3 f5 against
me rather I delayed the development of
my night and I instead because blacks
Knight is not already on f6 it means I
can play E for unimpeded which is what I
did efore Bishop e7 Bishop d3 it's a
it's a kind of a small violation like I
say you know you develop your bishops
before you develop Knights Knights are
the natural move but in this case as I
explained I did it for a very specific
purpose which is I wanted to avoid
comrades petrel preparation now again I
don't know we're comrades coming from
all I know is all of my nearest rivals
have defeated him and literally I got a
win I I can't afford you know to draw or
lose I mean a loose serious ground
against the leaders here here my last
two moves had been aimed at preventing
f5 right out of the wing comes a kind of
Benko gambit reaction now from a funny
point of view if you think about it if I
had played Knight c3 I suspect comrade
intended to take the knight so now on
his side of the table he wants to punish
me for not having botella play Knight
and the only way he can do that is to
place we can go gambit kind of move b5
takes a sex okay well you're not gonna
find this in any of your Banco gambit
books because normally you know whites
Knight is here or here and the bishop is
still on f1 but this is a crafty a
crafty idea in the Banco gambit because
if I take army if I allow black to take
and I recapture it's like it took me two
moves to make the capture instead of one
right so I kind of lose a tempo over the
normal Banco gambit variations okay
Knight c3 takes check here I'm an old
punk rubber man give me your pawns
okay so now we're in a kind of a Banco
gambit and what Camryn didn't realize
and was that I really really respect the
Banco gambit and in fact I think it's an
excellent excellent defense for
literally ninety nine nine nine nine
nine percent of people I mean only if
you're playing only against Magnus
Carlsen and other world champions would
you be a little bit cautious in terms of
giving up upon but in terms of
Grandmaster play master play
international play Club play it's a very
easy good defense to play for a mere
pawn you're getting really great
activities the to open filed the a and B
file for blacks rooks are natural in
this case the only thing that's a little
bit strange is the bishop position on d7
normally the bishop would go to a six
and the knight goes to d7 okay so a plug
for the Banco gambit do
and boy did I ever since that was coming
right I mean I'm telling you hundreds
and hundreds of hours of blitz play and
the gingy Indian Genji Indian had made
its mark felt on Cameron psyche and he's
challenged an Elaine Bishop takes c3
this is a terrible move come on I mean
it's one thing when I have double pawns
on c4 and c3 it's another thing when I'm
already upon up and you're giving up
this very very beautiful dark squared
Bishop my anxiety levels whatever they
wore let's call them ninety-eight
ninety-nine out of a hundred
after this move have gone down like 40 I
mean I wanted to tiptoe around the board
give my opponent and kiss on the cheek
that can sit down that didn't do it okay
thank you very much he gives up his very
very strong Bishop for a night that was
non-threatening Knight f6 Bishop t3 now
this move looks a little strange so I
might engage for a moment with my
audience here and ask well what what
what why did I just play Bishop d3 why
did I play Bishop d3 couldn't I have
played another Julian yes please
yeah well at the moment of course I'm
fearful that if I don't do anything
Cameron will realize that my pawn on e4
is hanging and simply take it right so
the question is how should I defend it I
could defend it with move f2 f3 me then
the knight on G 1 would be baying and
saying what are you doing I hate your
guts you take away the square but why
did I not therefore play the move Queen
c2 Queens
okay so Queen c2 right yes
yes exactly that that that's exactly
right
one of the things that I was thinking
and again considering my high high high
high high anxiety levels as to this game
I was really really thinking in you know
very carefully about every single option
that Camryn could play like every single
one and the one thing was like if I play
the move Queen c2 so in my mind every
move he's your plays could be
potentially absurd right like we're
playing a wild man here you know in
anything going to happen I mean we've
seen so many wild things already so in
this position as ridiculous as it is
what is an absurd move that you never
see in chess openings yes I mean how
many times have you ever seen black make
a rook lift the Queen side that goes
after your epoch not that I can't defend
it I can of course I I mean I must but
it's just a little of like okay what
possibly could he attack now again I'm
not so happy about playing the move f2
f3 because my Knights gonna get very
upset with me right so I would probably
have to play a move like c4 right okay
now after c4 in my mind's eye I imagine
that the knight was going to come to a6
the knight was going to come to be for
the Queen was going to go to
five I don't know what's going on I just
timed out the variation okay that's it
that's it
too much too much originality you know
like okay it's a night Bishop to d3 okay
and for what Julian said is correct I
didn't want to really give him the
opportunity to pin my knight with Knight
f3 along Bishop g4 I wanted to play 92
and again comrade was one of those guys
he's really hard to hold down you know
you want to you know a straight jacket
of but it's very very difficult but here
again because my levels of anxiety were
going really really doubt Black has
given up his dark squared Bishop let me
come on
no can do right you can't do that you
can't just give up a wonderful Bishop so
I've got it in my mind that one day I'm
gonna be able to play Bishop c1 to h6
and this move is gonna land like a ton
of bricks yeah baby that's my move you
know and it's just I just got to make it
happen just coming okay Queen a5 again
you know this is this is comrade trying
desperately to mix it up but the more
you think about it you know like the guy
still he is creating counter chances you
can imagine that when I defend this pawn
that black may play a move like Queen a4
which attacks the pawn on e4 and again
I'm I don't really get my my positional
grippers on them quite yet Queen a 592
Bishop a4 out of the blue oh like oh no
you know like where did that come from
and it's a kind of a funny thing once
again it's sort of like here I don't
think I've done anything wrong myself
right
but I had this very strange feeling
during the game that somehow I've been
put in a position where I have one only
move right I mean like wow how weird is
that
and when you you have that feeling that
you only have one good move it sort of
let you start to feel like you've done
something wrong my queen is attacked if
I block the attack against my queen with
the move Bishop d3 to c2 Knight takes e4
just grabs the pawn instead I have to
put my queen on I just kind of want to
say a little slightly awkward Square
Queen d1 to d2 ninety seven and you know
I had this funniest feeling that my
opponent is playing in a way that he
doesn't understand chest he's got it all
completely backwards whoever his teacher
is you know get a refund they're a bad
lesson bad lessons but at the same time
I have this again the strange awkward
feeling like this game that I absolutely
absolutely have to win gosh give him a
moment and he's ready to go 95 Knight
takes D 3 Queen takes D 3 Bishop b5 and
suddenly he's dominating anxiety level
goes higher much higher much higher I've
got to do something very clever
suggestions from the class what should I
do
young men for Julian also f4 f4 f4 to
stop that night okay let's just pause
for a second there how many of us like
f4 that's two three
mmm let's just imagine for those who do
like f4 let's imagine we play the move
f4 and then black would play the move C
5 c4 and then what do we do we don't
like to take the pawn because of
94 yes so f-4c for Bishop be 195
attacking our pawn on e4 and in some
times let me just show that sorry I
should just show that I apologize
f4 let's just say just for argument's
sake we just put a variation down now
besides the fact that this pawn on e4 is
attacked let's just imagine just for
argument's sake that we play a move like
Knight g3 to defend our pawn now after a
move for example like Bishop b5 we're
not crashing the guy on the contrary
Black has ideas like might might be
three taking advantage of the a file as
well as ideas of 93 that's like whoa
whoa whoa don't tell me I'm worse I'm a
pawn up right
okay so f4 is a move good move other
suggestions for white Julian again
knight Knight g3 makes perfect sense one
of the one of the greatest players the
greatest tactical players I've ever
played against I've ever met I've ever
seen is Gary Kasparov
but one of the most extraordinary things
about Gary Kasparov is he's really
underestimated as a strategic player one
of the things that you really when you
look at the games of Gary Kasparov look
what he does to his opponents nights now
this night is on g3 already wonderful
excellent excellent no problem so if
this pawn was not on g6 a Gary Kasparov
loop would be play g6 to strategically
lock in the night and limit this
knight's possibilities
he was really amazingly good about
reducing his opponents of options
especially with the Knights are
concerned so when we played the move
Knight g3 we do it for a very very
concrete reason we're doing it to
protect the pawn on e4 but when we do
make that move we do have to recognize
we put it on it we put all night on g3
on a square that has no future right
that the pawn on g6 really now the only
way this Knight will ever work is if we
play move like f4 y e5 one day and the
night goes to e4 so this is a kind of a
temporary move the other thing I want to
say about the move Knight g3 is when we
play the move Knight g3 we have to be a
cognizant and our opponent may not like
our night on g3 you may play the move
h5 after we play the room Knight g3 a
tribe we're almost obliged to play the
move h4 because we don't want black
playing h4 an h3 so let me just put that
on it on the board for a second I see
four yes of course of course we can do
everything that we like h4 now if any to
at any moment you like you can trade
Queens Julie no problem no anytime you
like you can trade Queens but for the
moment you got to worry about your night
yeah so let's just say for argument's
sake that you move your knight here and
after h3g 394 I'm getting killed like
like the whole world is like like the
world just caved in on me right your
anxiety levels went down from the level
of 40 elderly ricocheting right past 90
going up to 98 percent obviously after
this move not
only is the bishop hanging with a check
thanks to the absolute pin but thud
night a three check is also on blacks
agenda so it's like one of those things
I'm really really nervous and I'm also
asking myself where did I go wrong
oh gosh sorry to play c4 it immediately
in the words of uncle died immediately
c4 okay so cancel that get out of here
okay
so c4 okay so let's see how this move
helps us obviously the pawn on c4 nicely
nicely reinforces the pawn on d5 it
prepares the knight to a pretty good
square on c3 but my me immediate concern
I think would be Knight e5 let me just
double-check for a second suppose I do
something helpful for you I help your
development and I take the Queen have to
take with a king and now 95 Bishop
Bishop boy - okay if I can get away with
Bishop boy - I like that move very much
I did sorry let's go back sorry oops
here I gave up okay good close your eyes
that was a a wardrobe malfunction
everybody I think you hit the nail right
on the head yourself they'll allow
anybody into this club I tell you I
wreck things will come here to disturb
the class joyous take them out
yes yeah I I think you you hit the the
correct answer there was that night II
five comes and you're thanks to this pin
isn't it I mean how did I get into
trouble okay sorry pause pause pause
okay feel cleaned I mean hanging pieces
with check right this can yeah I mean
scared the most intrepid but hold on
okay let's see can let's say first of
all let's just look at the obvious
recapture then what will we do yay and
by the way I love playing moves like
king d2 and one of the things that's a
little bit off-putting about this
position is some time ago you heard me
mention that I might move Bishop c1 to
h6 was going to land like you know
Godzilla on the position is not in the
position anymore let's try the move
Knight g4 with a very obvious intention
after taking the pawn attacking the rook
attacking the bishop what did I hear
that right
I'm shocked shocked to discover that
Julian is hanging his hanging apiece
well the best I could see is something
like a move like rook h1 which may be
just simply offers a pawn black could
win his pawn back which of course I
didn't want to give his pawn back but it
it was it was remarkable being in my
shoes in this position trying to figure
out my opponent's guess
never mind figure out figuring out was
no no no no no it was a guesswork
to both the guests my opponents move and
to try to understand where I went wrong
or did I go wrong or what was going on
well in a number of the variations that
we've just discussed one of the things
that is happening is White's King is
vulnerable and you know time and time
and time again I will repeat myself that
in the opening your goal is only three
things three things in only three three
you want your fair share of the center
you want good development you want to
save King that's it right I'm going for
the safe King I Castle okay
whatever else comes who knows what calm
runs gonna do you know like whatever
else comes you know at least I've got a
safe king okay that made me feel good
he played 98 I mean after all what else
is he supposed to do if he messes up
moves like Knight g3 they're still in
the position moves like c4 moves like f4
are all in the position and in a in a
crazy way maybe one day the Queen could
travel all the way to h6 it's going to
take some time a little preparation but
okay there you have it 95 when I was a
kid I was raised that sounds a little
bit too strong but it made a very
powerful impression of my life who has
read the two volume series of Alexander
Alekhine's best games right only only
one person in the whole room has chess
culture a small small fee right and it's
a rental a rental charge yeah capitalist
system come on maybe maybe serious well
in that work in which I think was really
a wonderful work by Alexander Alekhine
is he had a game where where his
opponent has set a trap yeah and all
that kind says do today hear my opponent
played this move which sets this
beautiful trap and Alekhine started
thinking about the position thinking
about the position how do I avoid the
trap how do I avoid the trap and every
way every possibility that he saw of
avoiding the trap had downside so then
he started looking at what would happen
if he fell into the trap and he
discovered that his victory would come
sooner before falling into the trap was
a really really good idea so one of the
things we might consider for a moment
this position is that black is material
down absolutely spawn now and black has
down the two bishops clearly and black
is looking for compensation absolutely
so we might imagine that black would
like compensation by going Knight here
taking up off this bishop and playing
for counter play on light squares and
while I allowed this line of play what
went in sorry what went into my mind was
this idea that falling into Cameron's
trap was the best way of improving my
game right so in other words I say to
black says you be careful I'll take your
LightSquared Bishop I go okay please my
guests be my guests take my light-square
bishop so what I now realized is that
instead of being the
careful that my opponent would take the
bishop I would take I would actually
embrace that position because after
Knight takes D 3 new variation
Queen takes D 3 what would white play on
his next two moves
if white could have two moves in a row
what on earth would white play the
height is one of them Joey C 4 followed
by E 5 and it's just hey wait a minute
this is total domination right so by
getting rid of this night which was
making it difficult for me to play F for
an e5 and also blacks play on the light
squares is actually it's an illusion
there is no play on the light squares
Bishop C Bishop Bishop a4 to b5 is met
by c4 okay yes
you're channeling Cameron
so f-4c for so this is camera and trying
to mix things up he did not like this
move army night XD 13 takes D 3 C 4 he
didn't like this resulting position
Queen D 4
maybe he could have gone for it I'm not
sure so let's imagine what could
okay so Queen C 5 very very very
reasonable move
what verge alex is trying to do is get
me in a situation where it's a little
bit awkward to defend these pawns and if
black is very lucky he'll plant his
Bishop on d3 yep so here being an
obstinate kind of person I would
probably play this move
hoping to induce Queen trades and trying
to get my bishop on this line and
playing for the capture of this pawn on
f6 my overall impression is is that
black is struggling okay there's some
compensation yes but this moment he's
probably trying to get to rope in a draw
instead Camryn c4 you know okay god I
guess what what's going on and now to
the class what would you play is white
Julian bishop boy 1 yes
okay now you suggested that move rather
instantly and that is not exactly what
you should do
whenever you're in a position that is
quote sharp where pieces are attacking
other pieces and things like that the
first and foremost thing that you look
for is just check you always you must
you must you must absolutely look at
moves that make check well there is none
okay check off that one okay no checks
second of all you must you must you must
you must look at captures so you have
your force this is the rules of chess so
you forced to look at captures if you
look at the moves of capture capture
capture capture and go down the line and
you're not satisfied then the move what
you suggested Bishop b1 would be third
and one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]